hi i'm the greg rosenthal
and i'm going to talk about bounds on
the qac 0 complexity
of approximating parity
qsc0 circuits are constant depth quantum
circuits
with arbitrary one qubit gates pictured
here as squares
and generalized toefl gates of arbitrary
arity
which act on the standard basis by
flipping the target qubit
if and only if all of the control qubits
are 1.
more generally we will consider qac
circuits
which may have arbitrary depth
qac0 circuits are quantum analogs of ac0
circuits
meaning constant depth boolean circuits
with not gates
and unbounded fan in and and or gates
however it is not actually trivial for
qac0 circuits to simulate
ac0 circuits this is because ac 0
circuits are allowed fan out for free
meaning at no
cost they can create arbitrarily many
copies
of the input bits and of the outputs of
gates
whereas qac circuits are not granted
visibility axiomatically
for qac circuits to simulate this
ability we would like to compute the fin
out transformation on arbitrarily many
qubits
which acts on the standard basis by
flipping all of the target qubits
if and only if the control qubit is one
then by feeding and sili initialized to
zero into the target qubits
we can create arbitrarily many copies of
any classical bit
this does not violate the no cloning
theorem because the bit being copied
is 0 or 1 rather than an arbitrary qubit
this raises the question is finout
computable in the qac
0 preferably we would like to compute n
qubit fin out
in size polynomial in n but it is even
unknown whether qac 0 circuits of
arbitrary size
can compute and qubit thin out when n is
sufficiently large
the fan-out transformation is known to
be equivalent
up to low complexity qac reductions
to the unitary transformation
corresponding to the parity function
thus the question of whether finnout is
in qac0
is equivalent to the question of whether
parity is in qac 0
and remember we cannot directly simulate
the usual
exponential size ac 0 circuit for parity
in qac0
for comparison it is known that in
classical ac 0
exponential size is necessary as well as
sufficient to compute
parity finally
for added motivation not only can qacx0
circuits with fin out gates directly
simulate ac0
circuits but polynomial size qac0
circuits
with fin out gates can also compute the
majority function
here is what is known about the qac
complexity of purity and fanout
we're going to go through these tables
line by line first talking about the
prior results for context
and and then talking about the results
proved in this paper
we defined size and depth respectively
as the number of multi-qubit gates
into the number of layers of multi-qubit
gates
similarly to how in classical circuit
complexity
it is customary to count only and and or
gates towards size and depth and not
count
not gates
first there is a trivial log depth
linear size upper bound
this can be achieved for purity by
directly simulating the usual
mc1 circuit for purity for fan out
either reduce to parity or compute thin
out directly using cascading controlled
not gates
second qac circuits with sublinearly
many and sili
requires super constant depth to compute
purity or fan
out more generally there is a trade-off
between
ancillary and depth
finally depth to qac circuits cannot
compute purity or fan out exactly
when n is sufficiently large regardless
of the number of
encili in this paper we do four
things first we prove that constant
depth qac circuits can
in fact approximate purity and fan out
arbitrarily well
for example in depth 7 it takes
exponential size
more generally there is a size depth
trade-off
similar to that of classical ac0
circuits computing parity here the
perimeter
epsilon refers to the two norm error of
the circuit
on worst case quantum inputs
we also prove a nearly matching lower
bound for a certain subclass of qac
circuits
that generalizes the circuit from our
upper bound
this lower bound will be stated
precisely later in this talk
next we prove that arbitrary qac
circuits of depth d
decides at most one-fifth times n over d
plus one
cannot achieve much better than a
one-half approximation of parity or fin
out
regardless of the number of enclave
the definition of approximation used
here will be given
later in this talk and is such that it
is trivial to achieve
a one-half approximation there is in
fact a sharp
phase change at about 0.23 times n over
d
plus 1 inherent to our proof
an interesting case of this lower bound
is when d
is theta of log n then we have an omega
n over log n size lower bound which
nearly matches
the previously mentioned o of n size
upper bound
finally we improve the previously
mentioned depth 2 lower bound to an
approximation lower bound
where approximation here is defined the
same way as in the previous lower bound
in the rest of this talk we discuss
proof techniques
all of our results are proved via
reductions to the problem of
constructing
certain generalizations of the cat state
the capped state is the uniform
superposition of the all zeroes and all
one states
on n qubits it is named after
schrodinger's cat
because you don't know whether the cat
is alive or dead
more generally we introduce a family of
states named nekomata
after a two-tilt cat yokai from japanese
folklore
the states size 0 and psi 1 here may be
arbitrary states on an arbitrary number
of qubits
equivalently nekomata can be defined as
states for which a standard basis
measurement
of sum and qubits outputs the all zero
string with probability one half
and the all one string with probability
one half
so why are these states interesting in
one direction
a circuit for fan out can be used to
construct the cat state
via the well-known calculation shown
here
the first equality holds by linearity
and the second equality holds by the
definition of
thin out in the other direction
given a circuit constructing a nekomata
we can compute parity as follows
first i will explain what each gate in
this circuit means
and then i will explain why this circuit
computes purity
first comes the circuit c which my
assumption constructs an echo moda
then comes a layer of controlled z gates
each of which is a two
qubit gate that acts on the standard
basis by applying a phase of minus one
to the one one state
and acting as the identity on the 0 0
0 1 and 1 0 states
next comes the conjugate transpose of c
after that comes an or gate which acts
on the standard basis by flipping the
target qubit at the bottom
if and only if at least one of the
control qubits is one
this gate is easy to construct out of a
generalized
tough legate and not gates using de
morgan's laws
finally the second half of this circuit
is the same as the first half
so why does the circuit compute purity
first consider the case where x has even
parity
the first layer of controlled z gates
has no effect on the nekomata
so c conjugates transpose only computes
the necomada
back to the all zero state so the or
gate
is not activated similarly
the second half of the circuit has no
effect either
now consider the case where x has odd
parity
the first layer of controlled z gates
has the effect of flipping the sign of
the component of the nekomata
corresponding to all ones in the first n
qubits
this results in a state orthogonal to
the nekomata
so when we apply c conjugate transpose
we get a state orthogonal to
c conjugate transpose necomata i.e
orthogonal to the all zero state i.e
a superposition of standard basis states
besides the all zero state
so the or gate is activated
then in the second half of the circuit
uncomputes the state on the ancillary
here's how we use this reduction as
described in the next two slides
there exists an exponentially large
depth 2
qac circuit that approximately
constructs an echo model
plugging this depth 2 circuit into the
reduction from the previous slide
gives a depth 11 circuit for
approximating purity
with some further optimizations we can
decrease the depth from 11 to 7.
finally we compute purity in higher
depths by chaining together
subcomputations
of purity on smaller input sizes in a
manner similar to the usual ac0
circuits for parity
in this slide i will among other things
precisely states the first of our
previously mentioned
lower bound results
call a qac circuit mostly classical if
it consists of a layer of one qubit
gates
followed by a layer of generalized toefl
gates
followed by the conjugate transpose of
that same layer of one cubit gates
followed by any number of layers of
generalized toefl gates
we proved that in depth to and
exponential size
a mostly classical circuit can
approximately construct
an echo moda and its sublogarithmic
depth
and not quite fully exponential size no
mostly classical circuit
can construct much better than a
one-half approximation of a nekomata
regardless of the number of qubits
see the bottom of this slide for the
definition of approximation used here
where c is a mostly classical circuit of
the appropriate size and
depth note for comparison that the empty
circuit trivially achieves a one-half
approximation
how are these results proved recall that
nekomata can be equivalently defined
as states for which a standard basis
measurement of sum
and qubits outputs the l0 string with
probability one-half
and the all one string with probability
one-half
so i'm going to describe a procedure for
sampling
all zeroes with probability one-half and
all once with probability one-half
omitting some of the details of how qac
circuits
can approximately simulate this
procedure
consider a grid with n rows and
exponentially many columns
each cell in this grid will hold one bit
or cubit
first in each column independently
sample the all one string with
exponentially small probability
into the alt0 string otherwise phrase in
terms of quantum circuits
this entails constructing in each column
the state indicated on the slide
this can be done with a single
generalized top legate in each column
conjugated by one qubit gates
then in the second layer compute the or
of each row
why does this work if we're careful
about the constants implicit in the
theta notation
then with probability one half we will
sample the all zero string in every
column
in which case the or of each row will be
zero
and with probability one-half we will
sample all once in at least one column
in which case the or of each row will be
one
for the lower bound we prove a
concentration inequality
for the hamming weight of a standard
basis measurement of any n qubits
in a state constructed by a mostly
classical circuit
of low size and depth this reduces to
essentially a classical probability
problem
because the quantumness in mostly
classical circuits is only adjacent to
the bottom layer and in a very
controlled way
the main technical tool used here is a
certain concentration inequality
of govinsky levitt sax and srinivasan
now i'm going to say a few words about
the other two main results in this paper
and state them more precisely
first consider qac circuits of depth d
and
size at most one-fifth times n over d
plus 1.
after this slide i will describe a
normal form for qic circuits
once the circuit is put in this normal
form the proof basically consists of
many applications of the triangle
this gives a lower bound for
constructing nekomata as stated
precisely on the slide
this implies similar lower bounds for
purity and thin out as well
via the previously mentioned reduction
from constructing the cat state to
computing fan out
next consider depth to qac circuits we
kill off gates by measuring some of the
ancillary
in an appropriate product basis and then
apply the above theorem this gives a
lower bound for constructing the cat
state
as stated precisely on the slide again
this implies similar lower bounds for
parity and fan
out as well
finally the aforementioned normal form
for qac circuits is as follows
for comparison it is well known that in
boolean circuits
for simplicity here's a formula we can
push all of the not gets to the bottom
using de morgan's laws
like this
we're going to do something similar for
quantum circuits
here is a qac circuit with layers of one
qubit gates labeled r
s and t first insert something
equivalent to the identity
then collapse consecutive layers of one
qubit gates into a single layer of one
qubit gates
again insert something equivalent to the
identity
and again collapse consecutive layers of
one cubit gates into a single layer of
one qubit gates
now this pair of one qubit gates cancels
out
as does this pair of one qubit gates
finally group the gates like this what
we have is a layer of one qubit gates
adjacent to the input
followed by a series of blocks where
each block is the conjugation of a
generalized
toph ligate by a layer of one qubit
gates
what's nice about this normal form is
that each block has a convenient eigen
decomposition
specifically there is a single
eigenvalue of -1
for which the corresponding eigenvector
is a tensor product of one qubit states
and all of the other eigenvalues are one
thank you